[Musique]
c'est la dernière étape
ce groupe de chasseurs alpins s'apprête
à boucler le tour du Mont Blanc
sept jours et 170 km de marche un défi
pour Marc Timothée et Emilien trois
soldats blessés au Mali
dans une montée
à 910 mètres de déni
et après une fois au sommet ou on passe
par la Flégère et après c'est une
descente sur 1300 mètres de dénivelé
négatif jusqu'aux souches aujourd'hui on
a à peu près 20 22 23 km de projection
le 27e BCA ou bataillon de chasseurs
alpin s'est mobilisé pour organiser
cette opération baptisée Tiger red
l'objectif permettre à ces trois blessés
de retrouver leur montagne et de se
reconstruire
leur unité a été déployée à Gossi au
Mali de juin à octobre 2021 4 mois
d'opération anti djihadistes au Sahel au
contact de l'ennemi lors desquelles 7
soldats ont été grièvement blessés
[Musique]
je sais pas si ça charge
Émilien a eu un accident en s'équipant
pour prendre la garde une grenade
défensive accrochée à sa ceinture ses
dégoupillé et à exploser
[Musique]
dans l'accident j'ai perdu mes mains
j'ai été touchée au niveau de la hanche
où j'ai perdu pas mal de matière j'ai
une fracture du colis fémur une rupture
du tube digestif une fracture du foie et
puis j'en passe donc voilà j'ai pas mal
Morphée en fait à la base on devait me
ragondir l'os du pouce pour faire une
pince entre le pouce et le petit doigt
et
du coup ça a passé parce que voilà parce
que les le douanes à la pas fonctionné
quoi et du coup là il est bloqué dans
cette position finalement j'ai du
réapprendre à manger parce que je
n'étais plus capable de me nourrir j'ai
dû apprendre à boire j'ai dû réapprendre
à marcher à m'habiller à me laver comme
un nouveau-né et tendance à beaucoup me
comparer à ce que j'étais avant et du
coup voilà je suis encore en phase pour
faire ce deuil et accepter ce que je
suis maintenant
lors de l'accident Timothée se trouvait
à 3 mètres des 1001 en voyant la grenade
des goupillés il a eu le temps de se
retourner pour tenter de se protéger il
portait son gilet par balle mais a reçu
des éclats dans tout le corps un
fragment à emporter un morceau de son
mollet de la taille d'une balle de
tennis
quelques mois on était pas encore sûr de
récupérer le mollet à 100%. donc là bas
le tour du Mont Blanc ça me perso que le
mollet guéri quoi
j'étais poli polycribé du coup j'ai
quand même encore des éclats dans les
articulations donc ça pareil je fais
attention
voilà donc à voir à l'avenir
pour le moment ça va
aller on y va
on y va pour les échelles
lors de l'explosion Timothée a reçu 25
éclats dans tout l'arrière du corps y
compris le crâne aujourd'hui il en reste
11 que les chirurgiens n'ont pas pu
retirer
c'est juste ici voilà c'est en fait si
ça a tapé l'autre et c'est pas ça à côté
de l'artère et c'est celui que je me
fais le plus mal le plus dur c'était de
savoir que mon collègue il était en
urgence vitale ça c'était vraiment le
plus dur une fois que les cicatrices
s'effacent c'est que les blessures
soient soignées c'est là où la blessure
psychologique arrive j'étais déclaré
post-traumatique mais la léger voilà
c'était surtout des cauchemars la nuit
je me réveille la nuit ou alors je
dormais pas du tout j'ai eu un peu
l'hyper vigilance au début mais sinon
après ça s'est très vite dissipé surtout
quand après le collègue allait de mieux
en mieux je suis prêt à retourner c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que les gens ne
comprennent pas trop quand je dis ça
mais bon pour le moment là je suis
encore en construction je reprends
bientôt le travail mais moi si oui si je
peux si j'ai
si je peux y retourner c'est ça avec
grand plaisir
Timothée a passé les tests
psychologiques de l'armée et a été
déclaré apte au combat après le Tiger
red il prévoit de prendre part à des
stages pour rejoindre l'élite de
l'infanterie de montagne
le sergent Marc lui ne retournera pas en
première ligne son nerf sciatique a été
sectionné ils ne sont plus son pied
gauche et marche avec une attelle
il a été blessé dans l'attaque suicide
qui a marqué le début de la mission
malienne du 27ème BCA ce jour-là sa
section escorte un convoi dans le centre
ville de Gosselies son groupe vient de
débarquer d'un blindé lorsque le
kamikaze frappe
le véhicule est arrivé
doucement voilà il était pas il était
pas offensif
on l'a dévié de sa trajectoire par des
sommations gestuelles
du coup il nous a contourné et il s'est
fait sauter un peu plus tard quoi
derrière nous quoi
on a été huit blessés en tout dans cette
attaque la reconstruction pour nous
c'est une mission et de la réaliser
ensemble ça nous ça nous rappelle la
force qu'on a la force du groupe et ça
permet aussi à titre individuel de de se
confronter à un peu assez des moins
intérieurs quoi
après une semaine d'effort intense
qui marque l'arrivée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au Mali mais je suis super contente je
suis pas fière et puis moi je suis
derrière
j'ai hâte de voir remonter sur des skis
repaire du vélo
[Musique]
en octobre Emilien recevra ses prothèses
il espère reprendre le ski en janvier
avant de tenter l'ascension du
Kilimandjaro en juin 2023